Janelle thank you so much for making
time to chat with us about the Fed
this year in 2022 the FED has rapidly
increased its Benchmark rate from near
zero percent in the beginning of the
year to now four percent which is a
15-year High talk about the different
ways that ordinary people like me are
impacted by the fed's interest rate
hikes as they raise interest rates the
goal is really to make it more expensive
to borrow money so of course we're
feeling it in the housing market already
mortgage rates went up even before they
actually did the first rate increase but
it does trickle down to other kinds of
loans the goal is to lower demand and
that cooler demand should in the end
lead to lower prices the FED spend so
much time sort of looking at economic
forecasts to suss out whether or not
they're making the right calls do those
indicators actually give them a good
picture of how our economy is doing we
know that the FED relies a lot on its
forecasts because of the pandemic and
the unusual circumstances that we're in
a lot of those forecasts were wrong so
what we're hearing from from officials
now is that they're going to be looking
more closely at what is the economy
doing spending home prices inflation
hiring and even some of these more high
frequency indicators we know how many
people are making reservations one of
the things the FED is working towards is
achieving this idea of a soft Landing
can you talk about what that is and how
it's different from a hard Landing the
goal for the FED is to bring inflation
down while minimizing you know the pain
that we would feel in our everyday lives
so they Define that as like trying to
accomplish you know cooling inflation
without leading to a spike in
unemployment or at least limiting it to
a moderate increase as we head into 2023
what do we know about what the fed's
terminal rate could look like just how
high are these interest rates supposed
to get better officials are saying that
it's really uncertain at the moment and
that it will depend on what happens with
with inflation if inflation starts to
come down more quickly then rates don't
have to go as high if it takes a while
then they have to go higher right now
the market thinks that rates will Peak
at around five percent next year some
people think it'll be a little bit
higher than that but we'll see only time
will tell and it'll depend on inflation
and how much how much shift we see in
the economy
[Music]